okay let's go next to our caller from
the five-10 area code who's calling
today from five one zero hello
yeah that's your arm can hear me yes I
can hi I'm just uh I'm just quick I'm a
big fan of your show just gonna put that
out there quickly Thanks um but uh just
just to set it up my my question while I
am an ardent supporter of single-payer
health care I'm actually a bit
fatalistic regarding his chances of
actually ever passing through a
legislator a state or federal
considering the powerful opposition of
the healthcare industries and just
historically we haven't really had much
success there so with that in mind I was
interested in hearing your your opinion
on what I think is a reasonable
alternative which is uh all pay rate
health care which has actually had some
success in states and is actually
currently active in Maryland so I was
wondering and if you don't like the
alternative what are some other
alternatives if we're unable to get
through single-payer health care so
single-payer health care can mean a lot
of different things you have to remember
that when we talk about different ways
we could structure health and health
insurance and health care delivery you
can have you you can have government
involvement in the health insurance
piece of it but then the care is still
provided by a combination of private and
public health care providers so like as
an example Medicare is an example of
single-payer of which affects the health
insurance side but people are still
going to sort of like regular private
doctor's and a combination of course of
state-run and and and sort of government
hospitals if you look at TRICARE our
sorry if you look at the VA for example
for veterans that is actual government
health care rather than government
health insurance because they're
actually delivering the care as well so
I think it's really important to be
careful when we say single-payer verse
medicare-for-all versus nationalized
health care these are all sort of
different things and and what I think
you're correctly getting to is that the
obstacles politically to doing any one
of these are different depending on what
the political climate is and who's who's
in power so expanding something like
Medicare is very different than saying
government is going to take over health
care delivery doctors will now work for
the government sort of similar to the
British system so I think it's really
important for us to understand that yeah
I share some of your skepticism that
there's political viability for a lot of
these ideas but things can happen pretty
damn quickly once you get Democrats
controlling the White House the House
and the Senate obviously for-profit
health insurance companies are going to
be a barrier and their Lobby is
extraordinarily strong but in the same
way that I don't want to make it seem
like we're just gonna snap our fingers
and have some kind of single-payer we
don't want to just write off the
possibility because the healthcare Lobby
is strong like there's still work to be
done that can be successful here okay I
agree with you to it to a certain point
but like I guess I guess I guess a lot
of my friends also they give me crap for
this right I I want to okay how should I
put this from my understanding I would
have been doing a little bit of reading
on it is that all all peer rating what
it does is it sets a one price for uh
every health insurer right for any given
medical uh sorry it's just one price for
every health insurer for any given
medical procedure right right so I think
that that like I feel like that would be
more politically viable in terms of like
selling it to the public because there
are presidents and polls that have been
done that while the public supports a
single-payer or a single-payer armor
sorry nothing okay on Medicare for all
the support for it lowers when they find
out that hey they might have to pay more
taxes you know and be that they that
it'll in
that the eliminate private plans for one
government plan okay yeah what's another
of those things are true that's the
problem so neither of those things are
true right
what you have to remember is okay I know
it yeah so I think right what we need to
do is focus on the fact that a lot of
people are believing talking points that
aren't true but all the all-payer all
payer rating system deals with the cost
the the pricing side that's one part of
it but there's still a whole other side
to it so it's not a bad idea I'm not
disagreeing with you but there's just a
lot more that has to be considered in
terms of what which issues would that
actually address and which ones wouldn't
it but really good call appreciate
hearing from you really glad that you're
thinking about this stuff because it is
really important and if we don't think
of think through some of these issues in
exactly this way we're not going to get
anywhere